- So you had to do a lot of your scenes
with an animated character,
so how does that work since,
you know, that's not real.
- Yeah.
- A vivid imagination.
- [Kelly] Well done.
- You're staring into, you know,
middle space of nothing mostly.
Basically trying not to lose
your mind on a daily basis.
- Yeah, 'cause that would be really hard.
- Yeah you know, you get used to it.
It's like okay great,
I don't have to wait on
other actors to show up.
I can create my own actor
in front of my face.
- So he's the diva on set, okay I gotcha.
(audience laughs and
claps) No, just kidding.
I'm just kidding. (laughs)
- It's crazy that stuff.
It's amazing.
It's modern pantomime.
- Yeah, it is right?
And also the audience can tell
if you were looking at
something too far away,
if you're --
- That's what I mean, your eyeline,
- If Sonic's here, there's a
triangulation of your eyes,
you have to like train your eyes --
- I literally had to do
music video for Ugly Dolls
and they were like,
here are the characters
and I felt, I was like,
I'm gonna suck at this
and you did a whole movie like that,
I can't imagine.
- Well we worked with this
stuffed animal sitting there.
- Yeah, it's an early
stuffed version of Sonic
and his eyes kinda look like
Jim's on the screen over there.
(laughs)
This kinda glued on,
kind of an early, crude,
plushy Sonic.
- That's so creepy.
So something we both have in common
in speaking of movies and
roles you always take,
I said this backstage
but we both love singing
and you're so good at it,
you're so good!
- Oh well thank you.
(audience cheers and claps)
Yeah!
Like I love actors that come out
and they just can do everything.
They're singing, they're
dancing, they're acting,
it's so cool.
- Ya have to.
Have to do it.
- Yeah you just have to.
- Ya gotta do it.
It's like the old studio days,
you gotta sing, dance, all of it.
- I just do the one.
- You know what it is?
Maybe Jim feels the same way,
I was always just a mimic.
I could always hear rhythms of dialogue,
I could hear rhythms of music
and I could hear the pitch
and I would just emulate
singers that I liked.
- Yes.
- I could sing, it just was,
that's kinda where it came from.
- Did you grow up in choir?
- I wasn't allowed to go outside so,
a lot of "Boy in the Plastic
Bubble" tear going on,
so I used to,
imitate Johnny Mathis
and people like that.
I used to come up singing impressions.
So yeah, we can basically
fake our way through anything.
- Yeah.
- That's it.
- So can women,
da doomp, chh!
(audience cheers and claps)
- Ah, come on!
- Wait, what?!
- [Jim] Come on!
- That happens?
- I'm just kidding, it's daytime!
- Yeah but why would you
fake it four or five times?
(laughs)
Oh I'm sorry,
did I say too much?
- I'm amazing!
So wait --
- You coulda stopped at three.
- This is.